The Washington Post reports a Catholic
priests and former Klansmen never paid
court-ordered damages for his racist
crimes in the 1970s Barbara and Philip
Butler say that William HSN also never
apologized for placing a massive burning
cross outside their Maryland home back
in 1977 HSN wrote in an op-ed on Monday
about his previous Klan affiliation the
62 year old priests is taking a leave of
absence
Errol Barnett is outside hsn's parish in
fairfax virginia with the evolving
explanation for his confession Errol
good morning good morning HSN was
serving here at this Catholic Church up
until Monday that's when he revealed his
former membership in the KKK explaining
that events in Charlottesville just a
few hours drive from here prompted him
to say he's sorry but the Diocese of
Arlington says actually an inquiry by a
freelance journalist really prompted the
revelation for I said I said that he was
a priest I didn't know what to say
Phillip and Barbara Butler are reliving
that moment 40 years ago when they
discovered across seven feet tall
burning on their front lawn it came from
William Aitchison in an essay published
Monday the 62 year old Catholic priest
confessed to being a leader of the KKK
in his early 20s my actions were
despicable he wrote or 40 years have
passed I must say this I'm sorry in a
statement the Diocese of Arlington said
there have been no accusations of racism
or bigotry against friar Aitchison
throughout his time in the diocese the
diocese reportedly knew of hsn's history
and it was widely reported by the media
he was sentenced to jail time for
mailing threatening letters to dr.
Martin Luther King Jr's Widow Coretta
Scott King and for several cross
burnings including at the butler's home
but when it came time to pay the family
$26,000 in damages
Aitchison disappeared in 1982 a
front-page story published by The
Washington Post characterized the
butler's agony prompting president and
mrs. Reagan to visit the family at their
Maryland home that same afternoon I
simply told them whatever pleasure it
was to come and be able to visit them
here and how much I regret it any
unpleasantness that they may have had
because there shouldn't be any place in
our country for that sort of thing we
are Americans we're supposed to be so
why pick on one and not the other
decades later the butler's are
questioning the sincerity of HSN's
public confession we really need a
closer I will never ever forget that we
didn't deserve this no one deserves it
now the butler's not only want an
in-person apology but they want HSN to
disclose any other members of the KKK
who may have helped him the Diocese of
Arlington says he is open to meeting
with the family privately keep in mind
he still owes them $26,000 the diocese
says it is working with HSN to make
restitution bill thank you know to hear
a priest and a Klansmen in the same
sentence right takes a minute to wrap
your brain to ideas seem to clash are
you good